please stop
[Music]
hey there and welcome to my channel in
this video I want to talk about Sony
picture profiles uh more specifically
about all the menus sub menus all the
settings what do you mean and how to use
all these settings to influence your
image and eventually create your very
own Sony film simulation recipe so this
video was shot on the Sony internet film
simulation and further color graded with
eight millimeter home field bar grade
which you can find on my website as a
backstory so you can understand exactly
what this is all about for the past
years I've been working on this project
called Sony film simulation recipes
which are in camera picture profile
settings meant to replicate your
favorite film stocks and bake it into
your Sony camera to reduce the time span
editing or just to get better color
straight out of the camera they work for
both video and photo modes but for the
photo mode you will need to shoot
rubble's jpeg you can also choose jpeg
only but I always think as is safer to
have both Ron jpeg in case case you
decide later that you want to continue
post processing your images and you know
like these picture profile settings are
not will not be baked in the raw files
only into the JPEG but if you want to
keep post-processing the images also
prepare some film presets for Lightroom
and capture one for a seamless workflow
so you can find everything on my website
link to the link in description down
below so we all hear that Sony colors
are not that great you know and that
might be true but since this project
appeared people change their belief on
Sony colors and what kind of colors you
can get straight out of camera without
any editing pair of skin tones and just
you know overall better color over your
image cutting down the editing process
sometimes even completely so let me show
you some before and after shots from my
latest YouTube projects so you can see
exactly what I'm talking about you can
see how nice the colors are coming
straight out the camera and I barely
touched the image in post with some
conscious adjustments slight saturation
increase temperature adjustments also
adding some green teal Hues in the
highlight tweaking the cars a little bit
the color grading process was cut down
by around 70 80 percent and that is all
because I use the big thin picture
profile called portrait 400 which gave
me the kind of look I needed that saved
me a lot of time and hard drive space
because everything was shot on 8-bit
even Sony matches on their website that
tweaking the picture profile settings
can actually be used to cut down the
editing process to get closer to the
catalog that you want inside the camera
Sony film simulations will give you
better color better low light
performance and less hard drive space
needed for each project easing your
workflow it's pretty crazy so you can
always push the colors further if you
want to no problem but it already has
really nice colors straight out of the
camera and that's a huge work lift and a
Time Saver lately this project had a
huge explosion in popularity and since
there's pretty much nobody explaining
how Sony picture profiles work or how to
use it to influence the image today I
won't explain every bit of it and show
you exactly how to create your very own
custom picture profile recipe in under
30 minutes
so first things first you need to check
if your camera has a picture profile
menu nowadays most Sony cameras have it
included but you still need to check if
your camera has it or not but only to be
sure you need to Google your camera
model and check if it has the picture
profile menu important detail not the
picture effect but the picture profile
menu which looks like this so at the
moment the A9 line and the full frame
rx1r line doesn't come with the picture
profile menu hopefully that include it
in newer models Sony film camera line
every Sony continued with the RX1 or at
least create an aps-c sensor camera with
film aesthetic and more in-depth picture
profile controls like Hue versus you
here versus saturation and green effect
because we already have here versus Luma
which is the colors app why not add all
of these as well so we can cut down the
color grading completely and create more
complex film simulations for Sony
cameras that'll make Sony cameras truly
Limitless
even though the picture profile menu is
mainly focused for video Sony mentions
it can be used for photos as well and
the recipes will be baked into jpeg only
but I always choose the raw jpeg option
in case I want to post-process the image
later because if I take a great shot
which I want to print or put in my
portfolio I'll spend the extra hours
color creating and I need the raw power
it's always safer to have boat raw and
JPEG but of course you can shoot jpeg
only as well it's a film simulation
presets unfortunately only some of the
picture profile settings will be
transferred to the raw files and those
are just a few so it's not waste time on
color grading also made some Lightroom
and Capture One presets for a seamless
workflow when using the Sony film
signature recipes and you can check them
out on my website store so let's get
into the menu and see what we got there
the Black Level first thing is the black
level and this is basically just like
lifting or crushing the Black Point in
any editing software so as you can see
if you drag it down you'll crush the
blocks losing detail in the shadow
increasing the contrast and just making
the overall image darker so if you lift
it up you bring the Black Point higher
meaning you will be able to save more
detail in the darker areas and
consequently fading the blacks giving
your image a soft analogy but since we
want to take benefit of the picture
profile menu to bring the image as close
as possible to the final look we need we
seldomly bring up the Black Level
because we're trying to bring the image
to the final result inside the camera to
cut down the color grading process
almost completely the only situation
when you really want to fade the blacks
is when using it with high contrast
gammas
so for example it works really well with
Gammas like movie or still which already
have a steep gamma slope and high
contrast which in some occasions might
be a little bit too much so in this
scenario by using the still gamma we
have a Punchy contrast as a base and
lifting the black retains some of the
Shadow details
so for low contrast Gammas like cine1 or
helg I recommend decreasing the Shadows
to maybe
-10 or -15 since they already have a
super soft and fitted contrast and
lifting the Black Level further will
only make your image lose contrast and
look muddy black level will not work
with Ethyl Gammas only the black gamma
will influence the log Gammas which is
the shadow control so you can choose
between a range of narrow medium or wide
and either decrease it or increase it
foreign
it's the exact opposite only the black
level will work so the black gamma is
disabled
so either way Sony compared to other
manufacturers doesn't compress the image
so much so even if the Shadows or
highlights seem crushed I'm always
surprised how much detail I can actually
recover in post-processing
the next item on the menu is the gamma
and this will Define the gamma slope
which defines the contrast of your image
and is comparable to an s-curve each
gamma will offer different image to Modi
and dynamic range still a movie being
the ones with most contrast and least
dynamic range going down to cine Gammas
which are meant to replicate film like
contrast and finally heal G and s-log
which have the flattest image soft
contrast and most dynamic range to work
with
you can use them all to your advantage
in order to get a Punchy look or a soft
faded one when choosing one over the
other you need to think about the mood
you want to get what's the story how
Punchy or soft you want this thing to
look like I'll show you exactly how to
create a basic Sony film simulation but
first I need to talk to you about the
black ammo the black ammo simplifying
the black gamma the black gamma is
controlling the Shadows the range of
Shadows being controlled being wide
middle or narrow and you can lift them
up for a bright glowy look or push them
down for a moody look
you will use the black gamma in
combination with the black level and the
gamma going back and forth to further
refine your image this might be too much
information all at once so let me
simplify it I'll share a basic example
of contrast adjustments inside of into
resolve and how to translate the same
technique into your Sony's picture
profile menu
so whenever you color grade a picture or
footage you'll eventually increase or
decrease the contrast and you might end
up doing an s-curve that's comparable to
the gamma and by doing so you might
crunch the Black Level a little bit or
maybe raise them for a soft fady look
that's the Black Level next you'll push
down the Shadows to create contrast to
focus more on the subject and give a
moody tone to your image that's the
black ammo we can do all this inside the
picture profile menu so you have to
think the same way when creating your
Sony film simulation so if I want a
movie tone I firstly choose the still
gamma which is the gamma with most
contrast then lift up the Black Point by
maybe plus four to fade it out and give
a film like Vibe and finally adjust the
shadow part using the black gamma inside
the black gamma menu option you can
choose the range you want to influence
be it narrow medium or wide I'll choose
wide and push down the Shadows to -7
because for this film recipe I want a
smooth and long Shadow slope
so let's say I want to make a picture
profile for portraits emotionally want a
bright soft image so I'll choose to
bring up all the Shadows that I can to
make sure I offer my model a soft
transition in the skin tones next I'll
go back and adjust the Black Level to -5
to give a little punch in the darkest
areas you can also add in your current
picture profiles in the moment in case
you feel the image is too contrasty or
maybe too soft this is just a simple
example of how easy it is to create your
own custom picture profile if you know
what you want and you can notice how
much control Sony has actually giving us
inside the picture profile menu I still
haven't talked about the color modes the
color shifting options or how the gamma
influence each color mode because each
gamma will also influence your colors
differently so that is important detail
to know watching this tutorial helps you
understand how to influence the picture
profiles on the spot cutting down the
editing process
Sony picture profiles give us an insane
amount of control over the final image
and that helps us feel more inspired
present in the moment and not worrying
about will this look good after color
grading or how much time will you spend
only correcting Sony colors because I
know many of you are not satisfied with
the basic Sony profiles and that's why
you're here and that's why I'm here so
you can get more out of the camera
without the hassle
so these recipes are helpful even if you
plan on editing your Raw photos
afterwards because it's important to see
nice colors throughout the camera to
feel inspired and be creative in the
moment use Sony's standard colors and
you'll start thinking that your camera
should get or maybe that you need a
better camera or maybe a different brand
but maybe you need to know how to get
better color straight out of camera and
that will help you be more present in a
moment Sunny film simulations will also
help you with editing process because
you can use the jpeg as a reference and
say oh maybe this is how it's supposed
to look like or I could go in that
direction with the colors and it can be
a great reference point in your raw
workflow after working more than two
years on this project I could talk days
and days about Sony picture profiles and
I still want to be done because I still
learn more every day as I test
experiment and create new Sony film
simulation picture profiles only so we
can all get better color from our
cameras so join me in this project you
can go check out the blog for Straight
Out camera samples the link in
description
next on the list knee
the knee takes control of the highlights
and helps to retain some of the details
by compressing the brighter parts of the
image it's very similar to the black
Amma which controls the Shadows but in
the opposite direction inside a new menu
you will find a point which controls the
percentage pretty much the highlights
start being compressed retain the
details
they have the slope which controls the
maximum white level point
pushing this too much will give your
image gray skies so be gentle I usually
like to go between 75 or 82 with a plus
3 or plus 4 on the slope we can also
experiment on your own for color
profiles I wouldn't go lower than 75
plus 2 or plus 3 because it will give
you only gray spots in the highlights
from compression
I found black and white recipes more
forgiving in the knee area being able to
push them to somewhere around 75 percent
minus one and still looking fairly good
but it all depends what you want
the color modes there are 10 or more
color modes on Sony cameras each with
original color science and look so you
can imagine talking about each color
mode specifics would take a lot of time
to give this tutorial short and easy to
follow I'll just showcase them so you
can see the main differences oh yeah
also if you were curious about each
color on the color tracker is
representing I made a blog post on that
you can download the card checker
explanation on your phone for better
understanding
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
so after seeing all of them you'll
probably notice the differences between
them some being very subtle some more
obvious differences but as a starter
this is color modes to start with are
movie still an i2709 Matrix because they
all have very simple color spaces and
will render beautiful images with high
saturation
I think saturation is self-explanatory
you can decrease or increase the
saturation from -32 to Plus 32.
[Music]
next we have the color phase this tool
in combination with the color adapt is a
very powerful tool which will shift all
the colors in different directions
giving you different color palettes so
for example if you shift the color face
to a negative value it will shift the
whole color palette counterclockwise so
if we drag it down to -7 Reds will
become orange yellows become green
greens become teal and blues will become
velvet magenta if we lift it up to plus
7 the Reds will become magenta heels
become orange greens become Olive and
blues become teal or even green so as a
starter you want to be gentle with these
looks experiment and in time you will
learn how to balance out the picture
profiles with the car temperature and
the color filter creating more complex
film simulations
I'll push it down to -2 to slightly
shift the red Thor's orange now if you
downloaded the color Checker from my
blog post you know what each color
Square represents and you can see our
skies will be slightly magenta because
we just pushed down the car face to -2
so to fix this let's go into the
temperature settings and let's drag down
the Kelvin by 200 or 500 and this will
calibrate the blues and the yellows
shifting them towards colder tonalities
meaning blue and pink if this is not
enough then go a step further and push
the color filter ever so gently towards
cyan or green Amber depending what
temperature you like for your images
that will push a little bit more green
into the scene affecting all the colors
making the Reds a little bit more orange
and shift magentas towards blue teal the
color filter will introduce colors into
your image which is helpful to shift and
correct colors but you gotta know what
you're doing and to be gentle use it
harshly and you will attend your whole
image with a certain color which might
or might not be what you want it's
always safer to start slow and then add
more if you like it I have an in-depth
article on how the color filter actually
brought me closer to Fuji colors and I
showcased the results compared to
Fujifilm check out the blog for the
results and full explanation
okay so some people ask me how to use
the color filter settings found on the
website because it might be confusing if
it's your first time using these film
simulations so if you purchase the Sony
film simulation pack on the website you
will find different color setting
variations like this for example and
this is confusing for some people
because they don't know which one should
they use for this particular field
recipe and to answer this each setting
was carefully chosen to give you a
specific mood depending on what color
variation this film stock might have
given real life but I've also made
original film simulations like the
vector 100 which are not replicating any
real film it was designed to give you
more interesting colors and contrast out
of the box for which I prepared multiple
color variations for different moods so
you can use all of them but they will
all give you different colors
for example Kura gold this is a
simulation which only is the real Kodak
gold film stock So based on the many
film references found online it
sometimes comes out predominantly red
other times a little bit on the yellow
green side so I prepared multiple
settings to emulate all those colors and
moods you need to imagine so for example
these settings in particular will
overpower the Reds giving you a warmer
image the next one will push the color
predominantly in the yellow green zone
Shifting the Shadow's door is green and
skin tone stores Amber
so after you input the temperature
settings all you have to do is lift or
lower the Kelvin values based on your
scene until you're satisfied with the
image coming out of the camera if you
reach the max point of the Kelvin values
and you want the image even colder or
hotter and start working with the color
filter to get to the point you want it
to be but in most cases after you input
the settings on the website you only
need to decrease or increase the Kelvin
so you either need to try out all the
settings to see which is on your liking
or need to look at the settings and try
to understand in what direction they are
going
Okay cool so next we have color depth
which is basically brightness for each
individual color Channel and this is so
crazy because Sony's giving us options
for each individual color Channel
Uchi also has a similar option called
coma effect but it only has two options
the Chrome effect and chrome effect blue
and it's not as powerful as Sony's so
we're really lucky to have these because
it makes a whole lot of difference how
the final image will look like
so if you lift it up the colors become
deeper richer and if you drag it down
they will become better
so let me share with you a cool trick
about these when you deepen color they
seem more saturated they're not
necessarily but they will look saturated
and Rich which if you butter them up
they might look a little bit less
saturated so by making colors deeper you
can also increase dynamic range
preserving more details for example in
Disguise and change the way the film
simulation should be exposed
and one more thing and this is a very
interesting I noticed sometimes by
Shifting the color depth colors will
also shift their hue and I think it's
about Sony's way of dealing with color
sometimes I noticed by pushing the red
spider will make them seem almost pink
or if you darken it it will shift
towards red or orange you can notice the
color shift happening more often in film
simulations that have a strong color
adjustment but in this one in particular
it's almost non-existent this is a
really cool trick which I recently found
out in my experimentation while creating
some film simulations like the
ectochrome and the color chrome 64. and
that really helped me coming closer to
the real film stock so for this basic
film recipe I'll shift rats to -3 greens
to plus 7 Blues and size 2 plus 5
magentas two plus seven and yellows to
-3 this will give our recipe bright skin
tones with deep and Rich colors of blue
green and magenta
Okay cool so the last step for this
basic film recipe is to adjust the
detail settings to give a soft cinematic
tone so this was probably the hardest
thing to find out and took me about one
and a half here to actually understand
how they work because Sony seems to kind
of hide the explanation to all these
settings or at least not be very
explanatory to what each setting does
but finally after about one year and a
half I found out exactly what each
setting does and how to adjust the
detail menu to get the softest feel like
image out of my Sony I found these to be
the best detail settings for a soft film
like image inside the camera and I'm
sharing these with you let's not forget
we are shooting digital cameras with
super sharp lenses so the image will
still be rather sharp so I highly
recommend using a division filter to cut
down the digital Edge and also give your
image a soft subtle glow
I use these settings for the inner
detail menu and then adjust the global
diesel on my personal preference I
really like the global detail at Round
-7 for the softest image possible but
sometimes social media has such a heavy
compression method that'll make images
look mushy so the solution to this would
be to leave the global detail adjustment
between -3 and 0 or to add film grain in
post and that will help keep the image
together
I also have posted multiple details
settings on my Forum from the softest
possible to the sharpest for different
purposes and also the meaning for each
of these options and this is super
helpful if you're using vintage lenses
which have lower sharpness compared to
your digital lenses and we'll definitely
need a higher level detail or otherwise
it will destroy your footage so as a
recap so now that we have an
understanding of what a Sony picture
profile setting is actually doing let's
recap all the modifications we have
brought to the picture profile and why
so first I choose the still gamma for
Punchy look and I will fade the blacks
with the help of the black level at
around plus 4. maybe for a soft video
look in the darker areas they further
push down the shadows for a moody look
I'll choose wide -7 but if you want a
portrait profile maybe go for wide plus
five you'll need to test it out to see
I'll suddenly add 75 plus 4 to 18 some
details and for a soft compressed
highlight roll off
for color modes I'll choose still
because I like how to saturate some of
the yellows which I believe is the most
problematic colors for Sony cameras
boost saturation at around plus two
decrease the color phase at -1 or -2 to
shoot the skin tones towards Amber and a
more earthy skin tone this will shift
the skies towards magenta so to correct
this I lower the temperature by 200 500
Kelvin then push the color filter
towards Amber green to normalize the
blues and make Reds slightly more orange
I have an in-depth article on how the
color filter actually brought me closer
to Fuji colors and I showcased the
results compared to Fujifilm check out
the blog for the results and full
explanation for color depth I use these
settings for bright skin tones and deep
blue skies and green foliage
and finally the softest detail possible
for a film-like image straight out of
the box and usually I'll add a black
mist filter on top
this is the before and this is after
okay cool trick set one of your buttons
to live display on and off and you can
instantly check the differences between
the Sony standard colors and the film
simulation you have created let's see
the final result
foreign
[Music]
I made some slight adjustments to get
the colors that I wanted and here are
the settings for the improved recipe
okay let's talk about exposure because
exposure is extremely important when
using these film recipes and not only
because how you expose will make the
difference between boring shots or
cinematic film looking images and will
also influence your color
so first off I want to say there's no
rule on how to expose it's a matter of
preference so don't limit yourself to
what others say or even my own personal
opinion okay just start experimenting
and find your own way of exposing that
being said many people ask me how do I
Expose and the simplest most General
answer would be to underexpose by half a
stop maybe even one stop but at the same
time some picture profiles like Porsche
400 active Chrome or chronochrome 64
look better Overexposed and some picture
profiles like portrait 800 need to be
Overexposed by at least one stop
otherwise they will come out very noisy
exposed by eye I always look at the
screen and know exactly how it needs to
be exposed for the final image to look
like in my head and to cut down the
editing process as much as possible so
it all comes to your vision
I highly recommend defining your style
and vision and exposure will no longer
be an uncertainty
but as a reference I have the metering
mode set to entire image so it analyzes
the whole scene and I usually notice
that I generally go for
-0.3 or -0.7 exposure in this scene I
have a white wall which is indicating
I'm Overexposed when in reality I would
be around zero exposure or maybe even
lower I like a slightly toned down image
a little bit underexposed to save
details in the highlights also give some
contrast to the scene so it's always a
matter of balancing out highlights and
shadows you should have a strong
understanding on how to expose for the
subject but also saving as much
highlight detail and not underexposing
too much I like to say a balanced
exposure so just load some film
simulations go out and start
experimenting come back home and check
your photos on the screen that's how
you'll learn how to expose this is
Elementary it's more important than
anything because I prepared all the
settings for you so you don't have to
understand color Harmony or how to
create film simulations like complex
film simulations and color science only
to focus on composition and proper
exposure so start experimenting
Kelvin and color filter the Kelvin color
filter adjustments are extremely
important
so some people ask me if they can skip
the color adjustment and just use Auto
white balance because it's easier the
answer is yes or no but maybe no with 90
of these film recipes you will still get
better color than your basic Sony
picture profiles okay but you're missing
the true potential each film recipe is
specifically designed in combination
with the temperature adjustment some of
them will not look as good without the
Kelvin and the color filter settings
because the Kelvin and the color filter
adjustments complement the recipes and
are meant to cut you the extra steps in
color grading so yeah also white balance
will give you a totally different colors
from image to image because the values
fluctuate depending on the situation
for example we have Sony standard colors
at Auto white balance okay let's compare
it with the Sony classic Chrome film
recipe without the color adjustments it
looks better than any basic Sony picture
profile but it's still not there now
let's see the Sony classic Pro with the
in-camera color settings found on my
website
there's a huge difference if we compare
to the Fuji you can see it comes
extremely close and that is because I
use the color adjustments found on the
website Reds are still a little bit
shifted towards magenta but it comes
very very close to Fuji without any
editing and compared to Sony's standard
colors it's a huge Improvement
so I highly recommend using the
temperature adjustments if you want
better color they were carefully chosen
to complement each recipe
so after you input the in-chemical
adjustments all you have to do to adjust
the temperature is to work with the
Kelvin values raise them or decrease
them to match the look you want straight
out of camera and this is the
versatility digital cameras offer US
Film rolls are calibrated at a fixed
temperature which is let's say for
example 5500 Kelvin and that can be
limiting because you could use a
specific film roll in a specific
situation but with digital we can adjust
the temperature to balance out the
colors and get the color we want
straight out of camo without color
correction in post okay matching
different Sony cameras Sony keeps
improving their color signs so every
camera will have a slightly different
color science for example the RX100 Mark
6 and the A7 III have been released in
the same period but the RX100 Mark 6
will be more on a green side while the
A7 III is shifted towards Magento to
match the both I will set the RX100 at
M5 on the cover filter and the A7 III at
g.5
if one of the cameras is still too
magenta live the color face by one or
two stop to shift all the colors
clockwise this will balance out the tint
shift each camera has bringing them
closer together
after experimenting so much with Sony's
picture profiles in the last couple
years I started to adjust my picture
profile settings and the color settings
on the go so the picture profile gives
me the exact colors that I want straight
out of camera and you will be able to do
that as well after experimenting with
them for a little while
refining the recipes on the Spot Will
further cut down the editing process
there are pretty much unlimited
directions you can go with these Sony
picture profiles so it's impossible to
explain each possibility but I wanted to
explain it just a bit so you can
understand the logic behind and
eventually start creating your very own
Sony film simulation recipes
I noticed a lot of information to grasp
at first and it might sound very
complicated if you never had any contact
with the Sony system or with the picture
profiles and that's why I already
created more than 40 Sony film
simulation recipes so you can get the
colors that you want without the hassle
you can find the film simulation recipes
on my website at the moment it costs 22
dollars it's a one-time payment and you
get lifetime access to all the updates
and all new film recipes I create make
sure to check the blog for straight out
of camera images and for detailed
explanation articles or film recipes
there's a link in the description so go
check it out thanks for watching I hope
this tutorial helps you understand Sony
colors and Sony picture profiles and see
you next time
foreign
[Music]